hold on a second D AB bozos and homies
don't forget to pick up your tickets for
Town Hall in New York City May 9th it's
the biggest show we've ever done and we
want everybody there mix the standup
comedy plus you play a little a YG with
the crowd M we also have our card game
the round the second version of the card
game is on sale right now at arug
garbage.com it's over 50 of our
questions you get to play with your
friends your family call them trash it's
a fun game get involved arug garbage.com
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there welcome
back to everybody's new favorite podcast
this is R you garbage it's that little
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find that at the group
to be classy you're just a big old piece
of trash trash trash trash I'm your host
Tes Foley coming at you on a beautiful
day we're out back here with hoodies in
a new edition merry Christmas everybody
merry freaking Christmas if you're
watching this we dropped Christmas day
we're here with the with the with the
fam just the bozos the homies and the
boys just who we like it wishing
everybody a happy and safe holiday
season my co-host is sitting across the
table from me he's the CEO of Ru garbage
he's an international businessman he's
my best pal in the whole wide world give
it up for the flatbread freak the
chicken par hero Kevin James Ryan what
up gang thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you R VI subscribe on
iTunes full video available on YouTube
as you know those numbers are TR R
cooking cooking and obviously the
greatest website of all time you go over
there at
www.patreon.com garbage you can sign up
for I don't know about 4 bajillion hours
worth of content at this point yes it's
all over there baby we got bonus vids we
got Vlogs you you get at the $10 level
you get two weekly bonus episodes hard
feelings and an bonus a check it the
Freak Out gang and then also Town Hall
baby New York City New York the tri
state area surrounding area classing it
up a little bit town hall on Broadway
baby 43d Street I believe man we're
doing it's our biggest show to date
tickets are on sale at rug garbage.com
we'd love to see there scoop them up
gang and bring the squad and also check
out the new version of the rug garbage
card game which is available right now
for purchase over there at rug
garbage.com spend some of that Christmas
Cash yeah there you go you know your
uncle hooked you up a little bit and a
little pocket money for you and how
about a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinary old magic man
makes us all look good works the ones
the twos the threes and the fours he
crosses the t's and he dots the eyes
give it up for T-Bone MC scruffs Toby
McMullen everybody what up
boys wearing your Christmas best yes sir
I hope everybody out there's having a
nice holiday and let me tell you if you
saw a jello salad or a fruit cake at
your holiday get together you're sure
jello salad I don't hate I like not
saying trash I like an Ambrosia love an
Ambrosia really nope n fruit cake I
always thought was something from
cartoons and I maybe saw it what is it
it's like a loaf with a bunch with like
cherries it's terrible it's like dried
candy fruits in it it's probably not
that bad yeah it's like drywall with
last year's fruit in it that's what
everybody says it's always been like the
the the joke but I bet you if you make a
fresh one it's probably pretty good you
know what you know who does it nice is
the eye ties the Italians with those um
those box cakes you know what I'm
talking about I do not um God damn it
what are they they do those tricolor
cookies too I know you like them I don't
like we that we didn't like any of that
guinea [__] at our house that wasn't a
wow I love them might as well been in
[__] in Sicily or something they come
in like little boxes they're they're
like you know for holidays and stuff
like that but I'll tell you what I was
dating abroad uh years ago um of filed
the restraining order
of the Italian persuasion and she made
french toast out of them knock your
compression socks right off I get that
delicious yeah what's your huge
Christmas uh morning what what is what
is your Christmas
morning uh now it's going to be a it's a
you know uh it's a little splintered
you're man of the house now man of the
house I don't know this is all new
traditions for me you got to start
making everybody come to you obviously
we're recording this a couple days
before actual Christmas um so I don't
know I mean I don't know what my
Christmas morning looks like anymore you
don't know what you're doing this year
uhuh we weren't able I mean we've been
we've been working like crazy we weren't
able to decorate the house we don't have
a tree I I haven't been there you don't
have a tree down there the lady was in
Germany we've been [__] we've been in
like 15 states in in 20 days man your
neighbors probably aren't happy with you
sure yeah I know you got to really start
doing that up nobody likes that guy I I
know I'm not proud of it but it is what
it is I I I we haven't had a [__] je
you throw manora in there there's no
excuse for uh for Halloween everyone's
got to do that [__] I I I get it I'm
aware but it's just it was physically
impossible to get your wife you get both
you get both holidays look at you yeah
little Harry little brisket then get
drunk sure nothing wrong with that I
like the no decorations let's let let's
everybody know that you play by your own
rules sure I don't have to conformed to
your Society that's a childless house
yeah no no nobody liked that guy I I was
honestly I'm I'm very upset I was very
much looking forward to [__] going
all out real classy nice do it do the
tree have people even like you know even
have maybe some friends over do the tree
cook eat have fun and we just I mean
December for us obviously it was [__]
nuts we just haven't been able to
haven't had a chance to get there got
the pizza oven now got the pizza oven so
we drop the ball hopefully next year I
come out [__] guns of Blazing but I
don't know probably do uh Christmas
presents with the broad uh at the house
and then we go over to we're going to go
over to my brother's house sure I would
throw your mom in that mix to to loosen
it up a you know just to make it nice a
little bit what do you mean have tell
tell tell tell the piece to roll over
Christmas morning I yeah but she wants
to be with the kids yeah it's like she
don't want to watch him [__] her
[__] 37-year-old bald son open up a
box of cigars yeah oh dang I'm leaning
out the door catching a heater what is
it pair of gloves
nice could be with the kids I'm over
here smelling your farts pretty great
yeah you got to be over with the kids
she's got to go with the kids and I get
that how does she choose which house to
go to uh Lo locality my sister's way
closer to her ah there you go yeah the
rest of kib's family bare knuckle boxes
winner gets
Denise they're fighting Irish style too
knuckles in couple of Travelers out
there in the
driveway I one of them cat vents who
your M yeah it is what it is it was also
uh we've gotten very as we've gotten
older and obviously everybody has kid
like you know it's we've the the the
dress has very much so we used to dress
up you know Christmas Day Christmas or
even Christmas Eve we would dress up
it'd be like a nice sweater maybe jeans
but usually like khakis Sho nice shoes
like dress up like you like you know we
did it now it's like you know then then
we broke into jeans you know what I mean
jeans and a nice shirt whatever and it
still is that but there's more it's all
sneaks it's like one kind of nice thing
and then you're just [__] chilling
yeah it used to be a lot nicer we used
to do uh Christmas Mass uh Christmas
midnight mass on Christmas Eve back when
we were in WLS bery go over to uh Holy
Savior or St Nicholas St Mary's do
[__] Christmas Christmas Eve Mass
then come home have the [__] uh
pajamas laid out get up do Christmas
morning then get all dressed up and go
to my aunts same thing now we're rolling
in sweatpants chilling there's a chicken
nugget tray everything
everything's from a bunch of different
stores my cousin throws down though on
Christmas day yeah she leaves no stone
unturned plus you got football and you
got basketball it's it's my I always say
my cousin Kelly it's it's it's my
favorite day of the year go going to her
house she got a nice spot too they do
well I feel bad for basketball man they
used to run the show on Christmas and
then football said one side kid here we
come yeah it was actually awesome if you
dude for some reason the games are
always good like 4 you're sitting there
chilling watching like the [__]
Nuggets play the Lakers it fun all right
but now that that football's on kick
rocks LeBron yeah trying to see the boys
run down the seam they're trying to put
a football game on every goddamn day I
know it's crazy in every goddamn country
too Sunday Mond expanded now they got
Saturday Friday it's crazy it's all over
the map Friday Night Football I I saw a
great video of some bar in a town of
like 40 people in England Die Hard
Browns fans they're all over there just
going and then all them stinks it's
great it's all right mate so you right
out I wonder if it's working is it
catching I mean they're they're selling
those games out they did one in they did
a couple in Germany they do a couple in
England I think they're doing more next
year as well you don't want those
psychos all of a sudden they're setting
off fireworks and [__] like that flare
guns and [__] in the [__] shooting flare
guns into the Huddle shit's bad enough
at the Raiders games we don't need that
[__] got to get the UN
involved um Christmas morning I'll be
with my brothers mhm handing those
little rats a bunch of presents and uh
he does a nice little spread does a
little Irish coffee little scramble egg
casserole which is Big sure maybe a
French they might they would do that too
like the frittata or whatever my mom I
love it no my sister-in-law give me
straight scram now my sister-in-law does
kind of a it's not a frittata it's and
I'm not saying this in a negative way
it's kind of a trashy version of a
frittata it's like it's almost like a
like a square kiche with like the little
bits of sausage and cherry cheese same
thing but it's like not it doesn't turn
the corner for me I need I need to eat
half that [__] tray and but it's
never big enough it's like oh we have
this too and you're like what [__] are
we doing here the nap's just not long
enough by the time we get out of there
and get back to back to Patty shut it
down for a couple hours we got to get up
and go to my cousins and that's where
the real real real Goods take place I'm
try to figure out he also throws uh uh
Andy's homemade um pork roll and cheese
sandwiches God I love pork roll on a
hamburger bun I don't understand in does
in the oven hot dog pancake dude yeah I
don't understand why it's not everywhere
pork roll Le and cheese it's nice forget
about it it's all right is uncle Hank
throwing it around this year throwing
some cash around for the kids
uh yeah I gotta be honest with have I
have I been irresponsible with my gift
giving yes yes yeah I'm I'm yeah yeah I
[__] up I got a deep I [__] up I got
a deep queue for you what'd you get the
lady but I get the lady she's got a
[__] rock sitting on her goddamn
finger what are you talking she yeah you
got a wrist guard to help not sprain
that thing carrying around uh no we
usually um we don't get each other
anything I mean we did and then it got
to a certain point where all efforts
went to the family sure so we don't um I
was kind of the same way up until you
know we were like oh we're not doing
anything for each other maybe something
small whatever just you know whatever
then she's like I got hit with yesterday
or two days
ago I got got you something small and
I'm like what the [__] now I got to
[__] go I got to get you a tennis
bracelet or something I don't know what
the [__] to get and I don't know when
I'm going to have time to do it cuz I'm
[__] she going to get a gift card or
something a friendship bracelet maybe I
I might I might double down on jammed up
K's pulling up with with Cheerio
necklaces and [__] I made
it
yikes I might double down on the
financial irresponsibility and uh head
down to South Beach for a couple of days
so I'll bring her you'll bring her Hey
listen you're a good kid you want to
come watch me eatp 40 lbs of stone crab
it's not in season um no no I don't know
but yes um I got to get something quick
yeah the I got two days to get something
the kids all got banged out pretty heavy
but they're at the point now where it's
just what do you want and they they
basically text you a link they send you
the link yeah they send you link there's
no heart in that I mean they're getting
older it used to it used to be you know
I'd get them you know a bu of those
Legos and we'd sit there and we put the
Legos together and all stuff at good
time all that [__] but you know they're
getting older and they got they got the
fit check at school and sure he likes
the sneakers he likes same with my kids
they like all their cool [__] we never
got is that stuff cheaper now than it
was when we were kids no that we just
weren't aware of it no no no I'm saying
like there was one or two dudes and I
mean one or two that had Jordans when
they came out yeah no that's I that's
like stat status quo now yeah it's just
kids are trendy but they still a how
much is a pair of Jordans right now 140
bucks yeah probably depends so I think
when we were in 1989 when they dropped
or whatever they were $100 they haven't
gone up that much no they would have
been 40 or something no they were
expensive they were that I think that
was the big thing they were like a
hundred bucks yeah they were like a 100
bucks people were getting killed for
them and [__] people are getting killed
for him it's [__] up $64.99 that's how
much they were yep what the [__] Patty
you could [__] get me you Dum BR
[__] 60 bucks Jesus Christ but that
was everything's my understand walking
around in wild cats like an [__] my
theory is like you would never it's just
now more custom to be like Oh I'm going
to spend $100 on shoes one back then
spending 64 bucks on shoes it was like
shoes were $29.99 it's like I'm not buy
I'm you know you're not getting those no
you're not getting those get you the
rebok classics the Kensington Cruisers
man I had another rekindling of those in
shout out to double dare the Kensington
Cruiser man the [__] that all white
Reebok Classic maybe a little bit of
black in it I like the I like the ones
with the little the blue and the red
line the ones they gave you on Double
Dare they gave them away they gave all
contestants got them sure they were hot
in Patty's defense 64 bucks 1985 will
run you about
18263 that's a lot of [__] money
that's a lot of money that's a lot of
money that's a lot of money to spend on
[__] shoes even now 180 bucks on a
pair of shoes is crazy yeah is getting a
uh irresponsible gift I believe what is
it um I modified her
will I get the whole little cyanide in
her coffee left my brother to the garage
I get the
house are you familiar with small doses
of arsenic no she um she had lost
something that uh my dad had gotten her
and when my dad was you sure you want to
hear this probably not but you already
brought t-one
get my tissues um but my dad was real
sick he didn't really know what was
going on he thought he was like he could
still go out and stuff like that he was
like tomorrow I want you to take me over
to the jeweler and I want to get
something real nice for your mom for uh
for taking for taking such good care of
me I think that's that that's I'm
deciding on that trigger tomorrow okay
yeah yeah talk to my talk to talk to my
guy over there guy straighten me out
with the with the with the ice sure I
got Patty a gift you did I did big old
saage [__] scumbag Jesus Christ your
mother he's about to DB I got to beat
him to the punch she appreciate that did
you throw it back in his face I I was
going to say a big cake for her to pop
out of it the and I got her the booby
T son of a [__] goddamn married woman
happy birthday goddamn Catholic disgrace
sold her like
that yeah I I I get Den e the same thing
every year hasn't failed gift card gift
card to The Nail joint here you go 100
bucks 200 bucks go get your Manny and
your petty out the door got to get them
something they want to use though that's
what that's she loves it she goes that's
what she go she goes she takes the kids
the whatever it's like it's functional
with her we're a very functional family
my step my stepdad got the same flannel
every year for [__] oh holy [__] he
was shocked every year too yeah that's
just what it is you get to say get [__]
you can use and I was thinking about it
everyone in the Ryan gets a black cup of
coffee and and some time to themselves
you're not wrong there was a lot of w
gift cards take turns smoking heaters in
the garage give yourself five minutes
get your head on straight my brother
though hey if it works my brother though
like over like the last five years like
you know even when we couldn't swing it
we'd get them like something for the
house but like I remember the one year
that's insane to me one year we I didn't
get him like a [__] sectional yeah
yeah I'm just saying like brother yeah
for me yeah one year we got them um uh
it was it's like a it D made it was like
a a banana how do I how do I word this
you put a frozen banana in it and and
and I'm
listening okay they're freaks apparently
and you turn it and it turns into with
that hook that's going to make going to
make a mess it turns into like a banana
uh cream pudding Frosty whatever it is
yeah yeah got little Frost the I'm
looking for
yo hey the lights just popped on of this
thing this thing I mean this thing's
shoty dude um and then we got him like
an espresso machine last year like a
nobody ever uses that [__] no one uses
[__] dude no one uses so he lost a a
nice scarf I think a couple years ago
you had probably stole it if I'm being
honest with you so I'm getting him a
nice scarf and getting uh the
sister-in-law um a nice you know spa day
or whatever at the Joint she goes to K
let's talk about with that liquid IV
baby shout out to liquid I visle just
had one to cure a hangover feeling like
a billion bucks remember folks Santa is
not the only fat guy who needs the
hydrate this month that seems like a
personal shot at me I don't know what
that's all about but I still love liquid
IV when I was Sicky that's all I drank
I'm on the watermelon I love it man you
put that in like a Hydro Flask with some
ice and it's screaming cold and Shake It
upo suck that D hydrate you twice as
water does yeah taste delicious yeah
twice as water does liquid IV has three
times the
electrolytes of the leading sports
drinks plus eight vitamins and nutrients
that keep you going no artificial
sweetener zero sugar no gluten dairy or
soy or GMOs you're making a great choice
for your health as well as your
hydration I'm not even lying I had one
today cuz I was out there [__]
chasing the dragon we love it and it's
fantastic it just it's I I mean if
you're if you're work out it's great if
you're a booze bag it's great we love it
grab your liquid IV hydration multiplier
sugar-free in bulk Nationwide Costco or
you can get 20% off when you go to
liquid i.com use the code garbage to
check out that's 20% off anything you
order when you shop Hy better hydration
a day using promo code garbage at liquid
i.com do it Kip let's talk about Factor
shout out the factor yeah let's talk
about getting away from the old milk and
cookies you know what I mean pork chop
it's the holiday season make your life
easier make your life more nutritious
with Factor America's number one ready
to eat meal kit yeah Factor deliver Chef
prepared dietician approved meals
straight to your door they're always
fresh never Frozen love them just heat
them up in 2 minutes you can serve
dinner you can do them in a microwave
maybe an air fryer I don't know I don't
want to pay and Sizzle air fryer I never
thought about that Sizzle it up two
three minutes the sauce gets a little
more texture to it I love it baby big
fan uh been been using them since way
before they were sponsored to the point
where we were thinking when we were both
using them like let's let's reach out
the factor and they reached out to us
you go Wacky World with v freezer right
now they got vegan uh vegetarian keto
calorie smart Protein Plus meal options
no matter what your goals are factor can
help you get there you go on you pick
them if you're traveling for the week
you can say hey pause I want six this
time I want two this time I want 100
next week head toctor meals.com garbage
50 and use code garbage 50 to get 50%
off that's code garbage 50@ Factor
meals.com garbage 5 5 Z to get 50% off
do it gang we fell back we we stopped
when me and my brother were working
together it was like I'm you know it was
like we were like Shar the pot it was
like taking money from our pot like all
right well what are we doing here just
[__] whatever and also too we had I
had so many people to buy for
between F like brother sister mom dad
stepmom stepdad other
brothers uh then we always did a Pana
between the cut so it was like I had to
buy like 15 gifts a year it's like a
broke college kid I'm like me my brother
and my sister all got phased out it's
like we're not [__] buying each other
like a sweater and socks or something
what are we doing yeah I mean I'm not
expecting anything and you know me and
the bird I I like that that you know we
we're putting our efforts forward in
giving instead of you know being you
know give giving each other something um
but I usually get now I'm not I don't
care sounds like it though I've been
getting shafted for a while really yeah
I mean when's the last time not not us
obviously I love the gifts that I got
here when was the last time your family
got you like a a blow your blow your
hair back gift
I don't know yeah t got me a goddamn
lightsaber sure be pretty [__] also
be [__] weird if your mom bought her
50 47y old son a lightsaber I just like
something to play with on Christmas Day
an action figure a little spaceship just
something I can I have to play with my
uh my Star Trek Enterprise ornament that
I have on the Christmas tree that's
that's a shame I take it off the stand
and just for a little bit I'm all [__]
up on
Bailey's got to do a little
Intergalactic exploring getting uh the
doc and uh Cindy what what did we get
the doc Dr D we I know we got my mom and
Apple watch okay and then we got my dad
now was that you two together or did you
just jump in on that that's me and my
brother together but was that like you
like came up with a plan or he was like
Hey or you were like hey this is what
we're doing he was like I got this stuff
send me the money yeah exactly okay
that's very me too that's why I I I
sniffed that out you know what the bird
hit me with yesterday she's like all
right we got everybody these gifts but
it's like one nice gift well the kids
got a bunch of [__] but like you know
one nice gift for the adults she's like
we should I I want to go and shop and
get them little things like little
things what you know little things from
the open which is real sweet but need a
[__] gun to the back of our head Cash
Cash Money Talk brother C buy me and
sell me what you about yeah well then
yeah I mean I I'm just saying I want
cash cash is always the back sweat you
want cash why not who the [__] don't
this is America right the give me some
green back some tea bills something yeah
I got to cash I got cash talks I got to
see how uh everything has shaken out
with the with the kids cuz if that [__]
ain't [__] even at a dollar they'll
be [__] losing it on me so I'm going
to have I'm going to have a couple of
bucks just in case my whole thing uh
here shut up my whole thing with the
kids now that I'm a little bit you know
they you got a bunch of them I got two
yeah I got six they've gotten older so
the boys I just lace with sneaks from
our boy shout out the Mike down at uh
suplex sneakers there you go I lace them
with uh with those um and that's what
they like that's great but before when I
had no money like when we were like
[__] you know obviously way down and
out where I'm like I don't I don't have
$100 I don't have money to get [__]
train tickets home let alone [__]
presents would do something they could
something they would play with that
night 1999 sure some sort of gun they
each got like a
they like where they just start running
arounds and I go my brother my brother
and sister love to go yeah we don't need
more [__] at the house like this will
break or they'll they'll leave it here
at Grandmom's and that's that and it is
what it is like yeah it's good I don't
need more [__] [__] at the house I
always made sure the kids got uh fun fun
presents when we were jammed up yeah we
were jammed up for a while weren't we
kid man shout out to the Boos and the
homies we [__] love you yeah that's a
that that is a a good
feeling yes it finally I could get very
emotional about it if I let myself no
yes of course no I I I I'm constantly
fighting it back and like in in moments
like this of like going home like a
loser not going home like a loser
especially in like the uh in the moments
where like you know in New York we say
like you know you have to tip your super
and those guys and the parking attendant
like there's a lot of people you have to
tip the you know the door man at the
building or whatever it's like now I can
and not have to like Duck him oh man I
got good at ducking for a couple of
years yeah throw a flashbang in the
lobby maybe in January sneak in maybe in
January our the the the one bedroom that
we had die man I
[__] I duck that guy until like
February when I could scrape it together
hey by the way this is we forgot to give
this to you and you know they to a
Valentine's Day card sorry for your
loss and you know they need it cuz like
I've gotten when I would get greased up
would do like cash jobs and [__] around
you got to get greased up before
Christmas when youy that's Christmas
money yeah you need the money you need
to be like all right cool I can pay it
for it I can tip someone else I can grab
so and so a nicer present I can [__]
hit 50 bucks to the kid whatever it is
you need that cash around the 15th
that's when [__] starts hitting the
[__] rubber hits the road yeah most
of my Christmas money was Grease that I
got from uh you know either the
restaurant that I was working at or
doing something else like [__] taking
one doing one day and just doing doing
some cash job somewhere that's it's all
it's a [__] it's a cycle yeah you got
to keep that [__] spinning trying to
hold up the goddamn
economy keep this thing moving you're
not wrong man Christmas Day I'm [__]
dead in the water what the [__] that
going to do for me I'm running into a
Right Aid to try to buy presents oh if
you give me cash on Christmas Day
Christmas Eve I'm jammed yeah I'd always
find myself at the mall like on the
phone with my mom and then and obviously
as a dirt bag I go do you have something
I can give so and so she goes I got the
erector set for Billy you can give to
him I go done deal oh man you're pulling
up with Mazda Hot Wheels in the world's
worst cap gun yeah you still got your
Sparro at that motto didn't you fatty I
had to
eat [__] $9
slice you get the you get the green
light from Denise make that too will you
yeah set yourself up it's you got
something for the little one too yeah he
just need some to I got him something
throw my name on it and i' always have
to go be like an an's pretzels man I got
to be honest my aunt uh my godmother we
always you know buy your godmother
sometime my mom always buys it my my
Godmother's a very
uh she did very well she's a very like
uh Prim and prop like you know very well
put together well-dressed
uh you know
businesswoman and she would always lace
me
obviously and my mom just buy her
whatever you know whatever my mom
thought like it was always a sweater or
something from you from you yeah it's
also I'm like 14 I'm like what am I
going to buy like that she's go I don't
know what the buy you know what I mean
like what am I buying her be weird if
you did buy it it's the woman's
department at bosov trying it on nice
sweater got the sequins and the shoulder
pads every time man I did she would be
like oh my God my aunt like this is so
me great job picking this up probably
never wore it no but she did oh she
bought ni my mom would B my mom was like
this is so hard this is perfect and I'm
like at one point I'm like you're either
lying to me that you believe me or
you're dumb you're dumb enough you're
either way I don't trust you you're in
on it thank you so much I and then
she'll she you wear it and I'd see her
like next year she goes this is what you
got me last year I'm like lady I never I
saw it the same time you
did it was wrapped up in a box when I
got it it looks good on you though where
you going cheering yeah dud cherry juice
all over your lips fat little bastard
half a stinger
scumbag H and what's your what's your uh
what's your uh social engagement down
air I am going to be hanging with my
folks Dr D and send got myself a little
hotel around the corner so I can
skidadle whenever I please smart move
that's the adult move it is a game
changer a little bit of separation
between you and the fam around the
holiday is that's maturity that's that's
healthy that's my gift to myself you're
nuts you got to do
it yeah it's one it's one awkward
conversation you don't want to stay here
why why is it because of the dogs no
it's not cuz of the two [__]
uncontrollable golden retrievers that
you had to have [__] jumping around
everywhere not that I don't love them
but yeah you walk in those things start
doing Rodeo moves dude they start
bucking they're like [__]
bouncers it's nuts dude they do like the
but the [__] head goes down the butt
goes up [__] whining and it's crazy
plus the [__] bed Situation's tough
there I don't know but I I yeah that
would it would [__] it's I'm telling
everybody does it everybody goes through
it it's one conversation of like hey
it's just easier we but then she's there
by herself I I don't like that you got
you I mean you know you go over there
and then you leave and go home yeah I
don't know don't you go to don't you go
to like your hillbilly uncles or
something like that out in the sticks uh
we used to yeah for uh country ham and
biscuits whoa are they is there any
spots open at that table buddy talk and
they had a in their basement they had a
big fireplace and they'd Huck the the
biscuits they cook them in the fire wow
you say Huck yeah toss them in is that
what they called them down there hucking
them no throw yeah is it yeah Chuck Huck
I never heard Huck oh you can Huck you
can Huck you can Chuck some Confederate
[__] right there yeah I mean it's it's
below the Mason Dixon I know that much
keep an eye on this guy yeah now we go
to my uh we go to my aunt and uncle's
place they got a they got a cousin we
have has the same birthday as me 29th I
never gotten her a birthday present and
I
really laid it out last year and now I
cannot follow it without getting too
specific
um any
well-known bad
apples Bozo couple Bozo cousin Bozo this
Bo that are you talking about my uncle
my crack smoking Uncle who stole all of
our inheritance but he's not around not
like that not like not like somebody
he's always around not like somebody
that you know wronged anybody but that
little F black sheepish not even like
they buddy you're looking at him yeah
it's him is it you no no I'm doing good
uh no people like you you're personable
yeah yeah but I think to his family he
is like they're like oh there's to be
out there you know I pictur like hen
he's up there in New York City doing God
knows what smoking the devil's
lettuce I sharing one pair of overalls
whole family and pair of overalls no
shout out to Stephanie and Rick cutest
couple nice sweetest people couldn't be
nicer we obviously had some we had uh
you know my my family is very large and
extended by marriages and you know it's
a very it was you know for a very long
time it was a very spiderweb esque uh
mapping of the family and someone at a
party you know without give it was you
know caught rumaging through some
personal I'm not talking anything like
going through the coats some personal
belongings for gift cards whoa and got
jacked up man I just meant based on pure
Personality yeah well that's a
personality
BL rooting through to purses yeah who
invited sticky finger moik that's crazy
uh-huh that the last time they were
invited to said Christmas party you know
I'll say this you mentioned uh on the
Christmas Spectacular uh that you were I
might have that you were uh at a
Suare and they threw down some turkey
and gravy at you which I have said that
on free gravy turkey is crazy what what'
you say crazy good free gravy turkey is
insane preg gravy turkey what do you me
pre graved like there's already gravy on
it oh that was the case yeah it was like
cut it yeah right and then they laid it
I mean the presentation was nice it was
laid out like you know like you would
lay it out and then like gravy on top of
it well what I was going to say is it
kind of got me thinking even though I
trashed it in the moment turkey does
it's a than it's a it's a christmy yeah
it's a christmy thing a bird you cook a
bird Christmas goose I'm not hey you
like not everybody get their hands on
goose I didn't have a straight up
Thanksgiving this year either I'm for a
gobler over there at the WWA that's what
I dead Patty if you're listening to this
you better you give me a six foot gobler
and put a bow on it man something oh God
the holiday season or as you call it
oic's greatest trial yeah you're really
going to put that put numbers up against
that o I'm not because I look back at
like even when I was just talking about
it can't go overboard with the [__]
egg scr cuz they just feel like [__] all
day and not even from the oics I just
don't want to feel feel like that
anymore I don't want to be dragging
myself through the entire day [__]
eating and it's better to be to be a
little bit clean I have a nibble little
this little that you know what I mean
I'm going to try human I'm going to try
to hold it off as long as I can I'm
going to probably skip a lot of that
stuff at uh at my brother's stay away
from the orange juice he gets the fresh
squeeze and makes mimosas and stuff like
that throws it in your face um try to
hold it classic Foy move try to hold it
off as long as I can till I get my
cousins and she what she's because if
you're going to slip up that's where you
want to do it that's a Super Bowl she
Wows you I'll tell you she Wows you
after we grub on Christmas say around
3:00 everyone's getting a little sleepy
me and Cindy pop on that couch and pop
on a little film called die hard and
have a real nice afternoon I think
you're going to see you go out back and
[__] split a chw
Twitter the old man goes to bed yo mom
quit barding my
shits so you want to spark
up nice but whatever you're doing this
holiday season gang we hope you're uh
you're happy and you're safe and it's a
it's a privilege to be here uh with you
very much so if you're watching this on
Christmas day uh we yeah I mean just to
reiterate we [__] love you guys so
much thank you for everything uh you
know what you guys have helped us build
over this past few years specifically
has changed our lives and you know don't
think we take that lightly and don't
think we ever take it for granted we
[__] love you yeah it's it's amazing
um that being said we have some [__]
uh it's a goddamn Family episode at the
end of the day Christmas theme or
holiday theme Family episode so we got
uh we got a bunch of patreon questions
that are all within the theme of the
holiday season baby the holiday season M
let's see all right this one's from bo
uh one of the original 500 board members
shout out to you baby that there you go
that's what we're [__] talking about
Bo that's what we're talking about is it
garbage to visit a mall Santa without a
child it's creepy for sure what are we
doing here it's fun if you do it with
your boys when we were in that mall in
uh San Francisco or Minneapolis wherever
we were I two completely different
country or cities where where I wanted
to make you and uh Luke go get your
picture taken with
them my mom had the dogs taken you know
you know it'll be a fun bit you guys go
weird everybody out
yeah yeah those two on Santa's lot I
mean I think you'd have to have like you
you see the very cute pictures of like
you know the brothers and the the
couples do or the like you know the
brother the two brothers and the sister
doing it kind of recreating the one they
had from like 20 years ago or whatever
that's fun that's kitsy I'm totally on
that but it's like also why are you what
who what do you want that picture
for sure just you yeah Photoshop that on
your own time you know what I mean that
reminded me of walking up going I've
been sending new letters for 39 years so
I had to do a face to face this time to
make sure I got what was coming to me as
a kid I never liked it I freaked out I
knew he was in Santa Claus and I didn't
want any [__] parts of that guy I
never minded it now didn't like it was
always hot didn't like it now just you
just sit there staring at him waiting in
that [__] line at the mall I hate oh
dude you had Sho for like three [__]
hours with your mom you're in pennies
you're in bosov you're in [__] Macy's
strawbries and like I hate department
stores you're [__] sitting in one and
then you're like all right let's go get
a picture you wait in line for [__]
45 minutes to an hour I'll have some
[__] you know some local drunk have
you have you sit on his lap I do it at
my cousins every year and you know 10
years ago it was uh you know all the
kids were little and all that stuff it
was more of thing but now they're older
whatever but man I remember my one uh
little cousin she wanted [__] nothing
to do with me I I be like it's me it's
me she still didn't give a [__] I rolled
in with the bag rig she freak out every
time I saw I was at the mall [__]
trashing be here kid the [__] you're
going to R upkeep TOS that's how much
you want to be like to you pull the
beard off it's
me you you blow it for everybody just so
one kid likes sh start doing crowd work
it's Hank but this reminded me uh got a
text in in our family group from Patty
with the dogs and the Santa Claus very
tight shot and I could have swore behind
her is the one wall in our house so my
and I'm like that's weird but didn't
think it my brother text me he's like is
that guy in our house did she get that
done at her house she had seeing it come
over she's saying no yeah but I am 100%
positive that that is where she puts the
tree and I know the [__] walls in
house yeah yeah who's that [__]
scumbag huh she's probably going you
know house to house [__] all the
[__] widows am I have to [__]
somebody up I don't like that at all
[__] gentleman callers in my father's
home
disr I just now in this moment realized
that the whole purpose of a mall Santa
is so that the parents can hear the kids
say what they want like that's the rub
so it's like the kids say what no have a
list yeah that's a month before they
School takes care of that are used to
school you write your Christmas list oh
yeah you write your Christmas and then
they pass it on to the parents yeah that
didn't go to the North Pole you bring it
home yeah I think you br home and your
parents go okay we'll mail it we always
used to give it to at thanksg the
Thanksgiving Day Parade Santa was the
last guy in the Philadelphia parade I
think probably most Thanksgiving yeah
it's usually how they do it it's him
he's the last one and you're and they
have like L you know whatever helpers
with like bags and you walk up and all
the kids would put their like you hand
deliver to Santa you used to go to the
proper Philadelphia every year no [__] I
told you I was in it a couple times look
at you local C I played like a play like
a 1920s like what's his name Harry
Dickens first first kid to eat 40
meatballs in a row threw up on on Dao's
float I was going to say everyone of
your throat everyone of your floats
throwing candy canes you're just eating
them I was on the Lorenzo's
float eating the world's biggest
slice here he comes young Kevin Ryan ate
12 pies all by himself I just got a geg
of root beer next to me that's all I
need that's pretty sweet no they didn't
do that we would we would do it every
year and like at one point I but then
also once I once the bubble was popped
that I knew uh you know this whole
things a hoax I was like I'm not [__]
getting up at 4 in the morning go
[__] freeze my nuts off on JFK
Boulevard suck a dick now that's a nice
touch we didn't do that bosov threw one
down in wilbury that was nice but yeah
it was always Santa bosov no you got to
go to the Macy's day parade what's the
Boscov's Day Parade looking there wasn't
a
Macy's bosov ran that town they actually
did a good job man bosss they did a good
job they used to do the Halloween one
too where they had the witch go across
scared the [__] out of my stepdad loves
shopping at bosov and I felt like felt
like the lights were flickering in there
every time I was in there it was [__]
down and out I like it it was this the
80s it was nice ah no they were the only
bosow around me I think was in the
nisham mall and it
was it was like it was at the end of the
mall nobody went to you know what I mean
you're walking by like empty kiosks and
[__] and this is in the 9s too you know
what really burst the bubble of a mall
department store like a Macy's or a
bloomies when you go downstairs and you
bump into their clearance section oh
yeah whoa like a tractor next to a
leather jacket [__] talk about seeing
the carracks yeah for sure I've been in
man that's so funny I just think about
it I remember being in there a couple of
years ago with the broad trying to
figure out how we were going to get
scrape money together to get [__]
presents for for like my looking in the
clearance like an old like Martini mixer
with a dent in it dude I was you're
white as a ghost from selling your
plasma your lips are all chapped
D you're Jam you look like you look like
powder I think I could do make one more
donation I was big on my mom got is the
clearance price written on here or is
that what you take off I don't
understand
no that was no good I that didn't come
out right you know they say did you just
donate plasma before what the [__] you
know they say get this guy shot orange
juice you know they say 20% off is it
20% off of what's on there or do you
take 20% off of what's on there mhm
anyway I was good on a $14 picture frame
for my mom picture frames all right no I
wouldn't put the picture in it but there
was just a it's for the yeah I put it
they knew they knew what I was doing
sure and mean my [__]
[Music]
jerk off of a brother was making money
and man I looked like a bozo he'd come
in and like floss with like a new phone
December to remember event oh yeah
there's a [__] Hyundai out front and
I'm like I got I dude you're wrapp it up
your old your old baseball mitt I bought
it I knew when I bought it I was also
big on like at least as long as it looks
good on the unveiling it doesn't have to
be great but like oh it's got some size
to it or something I bought I don't know
if I ordered online or what and I dude
it was you remember like it was like a
picture frames but it was like it was
like a run a string and it had like the
paper CLP or the clothes pins on it and
you would like you know it was like
kitsy or whatever oh you could yeah yeah
yeah had like little clothes spins and
like you know make a little collage coll
well I I know but it came just like it's
a all it is is a string in like four or
five little Clips so he came in like a
bag it came in like a dime bag and I was
like here you go meanwhile she's she's
got like a new [__] BMW for my
brother out front and I was looking I'm
like you know what you're doing you know
you're just walking past the living room
hearing her going he's
trying dude it's so funny my my my aunt
hit me my aunt my cousin hit me with
that she's like oh she's like I hadn't
seen her in like you know a couple
months or whatever she's like everything
looks like it's going so well
congratulations I'm like oh thanks she's
like did you could you ever have thought
I go honestly no no whatever she goes
man we would all talk about we would all
be like maybe he should just give it up
and really yeah and I was like yeah I
had those same conversations with myself
this hurts right now at the Christmas
party I started I started throwing 20s
around well [__] you're drinking a glass
of turkey
gravy you have to do this
now yeah no dude you were man what the
[__] they were saying that was Jesus you
were a young man when you started what
you were I mean not I mean I wasn't a
young man [__] three years ago damn
still you're in your 30s damn that means
my family must have been trashing me oh
dude [__] 44 and Ed up jammed up it's
uh yeah it was very uh and like I get it
you have to have like I was I mean
obviously not only one tiets SK I know
now they're all looking for the tick
where were you when I was
walking he the man said um I but that
being said we had this conversation my
family was crazy supportive very we used
to do show we used to do 80 person shows
on Fair Mount I think that was mostly
your brother and your cousins just
looking to get in fights wanting
somebody to Heckle you so they do them
up that's not dude I mean we would do we
would do shows the Center City comedy
show and what was that part not even
that we would do open mics I remember
them I remember like five of your
cousins coming to and Open Mic at Irish
Times yeah they turned that it was like
two tiered like you the St the stage the
performer stood down on the ground floor
and then there was like 5et up like a
ball it was like a don't like there was
a and like dude you had to like look up
and it was a bunch of [__] Pipe
Fitters and [__] guys who hang
sheetrock it was ugly yeah it was nice
yeah they showed up for us they came out
to the boys we used to do shows for 80
people used to sell like 80 tickets at
what's that bar the tavern on Urban
Saloon Urban Saloon
and we would sell 880 tickets and all 80
tickets would be friends and F like your
mom and dad and brother would come you
know sister-in-law whatever it's less of
a show more of a talent show that's all
it was and we were like oh we're doing
it I'm like I have everybody's phone
number in here like there all of these
people are in my phone you're just doing
a recital yeah it was it was bad oh ho
I'm dressed up like a
[Music]
tooth yeah yeah man we you know but they
would come out in droves and they still
do they were very supportive Town Hall
May 9th baby no one's getting tickets to
that bought it a saw it let's go all
right this one's from
Ethan uh is it garbage to get hammered
at your family's Christmas party and
explain to your uncle for 45 minutes
that he should get a Squatty Potty that
is one of those things you get a couple
in you and you're like no you don't know
it's a game changer I've been that guy
like you have no clue about something
that's new to you the worst part the
worst thing you can do for pretty much
anybody and it happens everybody does it
something new that you're excited about
and six drinks you will not shut the
[__] up about it I thing your [__] to
clean it you don't even wipe sometimes I
got a couple of old heads cuz you know
the old guard is you know dwindling
we're we're down to the last couple of
dads and uncles in in in the in the
festivities I'm going to have a couple
and [__] pull up next to next to a
couple of them and [__] hash it up a
little bit sure yeah yeah we just did we
were all cuz you can get them going so
easily oh yeah just like throw a ball
up yeah if you can get your uncle to
start a sentence with the real problem
in this country oh dude how more
Manhattans please you mentioned Tucker
they're [__] perked up [__] in
your
face just spitting them yeah yeah
wait he talk to your and you're doing
the other side both I'm just looking for
a fight
baby uh all right let's see um this
one's from Foy lies rude name to say
about my friend but true uh or is
it um thoughts on having a Christmas
tree as a single guy who lives alone
yeah man I don't know no yeah that's
[__] dude you got to why no no that's
too I mean you can't invite people over
then the [__] you can't you can't you
can't be trying you hold on you can't
bring a a girl over to your
house to try to close some it looks like
you murdered the family that lived there
that's too weird dude I
disagree I strongly disag I think that's
that shows that you know you're [__]
you know you're doing you and I like
that yeah but you is just weird to me a
single guy sets up a full Christmas tree
a full Christmas tree is what are you
supposed to not have a a you know live
your life and you know make a home just
cuz you're a single dude I mean you also
you're so forward you've never did it I
could never swing
it never swing it if you can afford a
nice tree and stuff like that yeah it's
a weird way to tell people you drink
alone cuz no one's decorating that thing
sober dude and if you are that's even
weird
that's what I'm saying there's just a
lot of times and I think if you're along
the I'm not saying it's not festive sure
I'll give you that if you're abroad and
you're looking for a husband and you go
in oh this guy's got his own tree that
would be too weird he's a family man
he's not that's the weird part he's he
he's playing family man there's not
there's not a murdered until he [__]
drowned everybody somewhere you better
go check his freezer for heads yeah that
family's in a [__] Toyota Camry at
the bottom of the looking at the
ornaments are these ears yeah uh I mean
I get that's what I'm saying I get it in
spirit I'm not [__] on it that's
very but I it's a little it's a little
weird I feel right a decoration of
something for sure a full-blown that's
got to be the saddest Christmas morning
in the world oh underwear your opening
presents you wrapped in [__] that's I I
don't know if they're doing that I think
it's just for decoration I'm joking
relax what the [__] did you write this
question what the [__] I I think you're
very defensive about it if and if it's a
real tree too that's even weirder cuz
they're they're you're going you're
picking it out they're wrapping it up
tree for the tree for the family huh
something like that yeah you're crawling
under there and watering it and [__]
yeah I always think about that one happy
days where Fonzi wouldn't go down and
have uh Christmas with the cutting hams
he's N I got big stuff going on I got to
do this and then Richie found him
upstairs eating a cold can of beans by
himself and they then he brought him
down yeah sure what the [__] yeah I mean
I'm not saying that it's a goddamn comp
podcast first of all I'm [__] on the
guy it's a little weird yeah I don't
care if he does it genuinely I was doing
it for comedic effect I think it's a
little creepy you took it crazy personal
I did now if he's got a missile toe in
there jerking off under it he's probably
got that in the lobby of the building
all right this one's from Michael your
dad ever shoved the whole Christmas tree
in the fireplace and caused $5,000 in
Spoke damage on New Year's Day
whoa you can't do that man that's crazy
and smoke damage that f going to go up
to chimney
yeah pouring out a whole Christmas tree
that's those those things especially if
they're dry those things go up smoke
yeah creating smoke those evergreens are
mostly smoke when you burn them yeah
yeah it's all water and [__] in there so
it's like [__] that's like that's
what causes all the [__] smoke that's
how you start a chimney fire yeah that's
how you start that's how you burn a
[__] building down what are you
talking about that's if you chop it up
and do it piece by piece that's guy over
a couple
hours no what no yeah this is well this
one's from Carlos is a garbage that burn
your Christmas tree we used to collect
them for a New Year's Eve bonfire that's
kind of fun KY to me I get that that's
ni you and the neighbors or whatever hey
we all go we'll pull them in the back
everybody pull out the chairs that we'll
get hot cocoa hot totties whatever you
got that's that's fun to me we never did
any of that I don't know why there was
people in our neighborhood that did it
but like before they put the the the
above ground pool in we had like a that
was like a regular backyard but we never
like burned leaves or anything anything
like that do you ever do any of that
[__] now I think they I don't think we
were allowed I think it's like a certain
you need a certain footage or acreage or
whatever that' be have like a burn pit
or something I think they got rid of
that that was like early on I think in
the 80s and [__] and I think the '90s
they shut that down walking through uh
the neighborhood on a Cris fall day and
just smell burning leaves yeah it is
nice knowing there was a chicken all a
crumb waiting for you back at the house
with Patty you know what's real fancy
that some places do I don't know if
we've talked about this is like you push
all the leaves out to the street and
then like they'll come vacuum them up
they did that for a minute some some of
like the small nice towns still do it
yeah you just push them all out to the
street and like big vacuum comes in my
the one guy landscape for bought one of
those one year he had the [__] thing
he put it on his truck that had sucker
the sucker man you couldn't tell us [__]
those things look fun to operate dude it
was nuts talk about making it easy it's
like as cool as a [__] driving a
forklift yeah cleaning up leaves in the
fall Landscaping was brutal but very
satisfying once it was all done um while
we're on the thing of trees this is from
Christian ever had a family member or
yourself fall into the tree dot dot dot
be
honest no no I don't think so definitely
had a dog or two russle like get behind
it and you like really got to [__]
get them out but never had one fall no
uh my dad used to get I'm not even
joking a 14t tree and then cut the top
half off so it was like flat he had like
you know like a high top fade he had and
we were like what the [__] cut it from
the bottom you wacko always high top
fade that getting that thing out and
setting that up was you know borderline
Psychopaths yelling at it like it that
was tense we cut one down in our front
yard one time but they I don't even know
if it was an actual Christmas tree but
it it was some some type of that Pine or
something but it was really more of a
bush cuz it was fat and there was like
four of them like as a as a property
line I don't know why I guess they were
they were jammed up my dad went out
there one
Saturday sliced it down so it was like
tree tree nothing stump tree tree it was
weird and put that thing in there and it
was huge it was so big I saw a great
video recently of a guy filming from his
car filming another car with a giant
Christmas tree on it he's going can't
hide money 14t ceilings in that house
yeah big ceilings are nice oh you ever
walk into somebody's house where they
have two trees they have one like in the
foyer like you know and like they have
no like the way your house is how you
walk in and my house my mom's house yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's not big enough to
put a tree in there I guess if it was a
little bit bigger if you had one in
there man we had two trees back into the
two trees Christmas tree and then a
birthday tree for me oh that's right oh
I don't remember that that's bad I got
in the local paper it was very
embarrassing jeez it's a sweet in next
to each other one was in you had that
kind of square footage at the house yeah
huh like you yeah one was I mean not a
very big house but we had like one was
in the living room by the kitchen and
then we had the what's the dining room I
guess it would be where the other one
what do you mean living room dining room
is where you eat living room yeah like a
more formal seated so I mean those are
the two big rooms in every house
generally yeah so that's one one in each
huh what was what would they decorate
the birthday tree with on the the topper
was the little hat they gave me as a
baby at the at the hospital I don't
remember any of this your brother had to
not like that no one liked it it was so
embarrassing uh just a real a real
Monument to a to a friendless
birthday I just imagine your Mom calling
people in your school like you want to
come over and stare at Toby's tree for a
little bit he could really use the
company
he yakes did you ever have that your
friend the mom's reach
out like a mom I remember a mom
called to see if I would play with her
son when I was like too old for that to
be like I answered the phone you and
she's like hey this is Mrs like no I got
work yeah she's like hey is this is Mrs
Smith I was like oh hey and she's like
is your mother home I go for what cuz
I'm playing defense on this call Lady
[__] I was sleeping all day yeah you
think I'm just going to [__] turn the
phone over to you [__] blindly sure
one second
hello yeah let me get her ma I was like
yeah no I was like what's this about
she's like I want to see if I can set up
a you know a time when you she know it
was you she was talking to me I didn't
fake I just go W thought you were your
deep voice I was like no she's at work
right now or something and lady you're
never getting through uh she's like I
wasn't sure if it was was like Kevin's
being mean though you know I I wasn't
letting that wasn't letting that wasn't
letting her them them to talk and she's
like yeah you want I hit this fat [__]
with a Wet Willie yeah she's like it's a
you know I want to see if you and Steve
or whatever wanted to set up a time
where you could come over you know and
play with Steve and I was like ah yeah I
got finals or
something the boss is riding me how old
were you too old for that I was smoking
sigs probably too old for 13 12 May yeah
like too old for that to be happening po
sixth grade maybe seventh grade no it
had to be junior high cuz we didn't go
to elementary school
togetherly [__] so it had to be seventh
grade and I was already into
heille how many people did that guy end
up murdering it's actually I mean we
were always like kind of friend you know
we were friendly but I was like no I'm
good I think I remember once I did that
and it was it was a nice time we didn't
really hit it off me and the kid though
M it was something like my mom knew his
mom or something like that went over
there yeah we had one I think he had
some Top Shelf toys or something like
that the mom really threw the you know
the snack and lunch you know bag at us
pretty hard you know sure celebrity
rolling in sure you know uh I got paid
for my time we had one kid I went over
his house and they him and his brother
they were like cool normal we like got
along we like really riffed together
well as like young kid like you know
just like in school in class or whatever
and uh I went over his house and they
they were really into Davey Crockett or
something and we were playing Ali Ali
oxen or something like that you know
that where you scream Ali Ali oxen free
I never knew what what what the
guidelines of the Gameware after
screaming oh I didn't stick around to
find out dude those two kids came down
the basement with raccoon hats on and I
said I said dude I'm [__] gone not
doing
that uh all right let's do uh let's do
we got time for one more here and then
we got a rizle um this one's from the
the mighty Locker is it garbage if you
know where the local Christmas tree
stands throw their unsold trees in the
wood chip piles at the local parks on
December 23rd so you wait and grab one
throw in the house for free whoa I
respect that I respect it you're gaming
you're gaming the system you're getting
a free tree two days before Christmas
and their tree prices are [__]
they're insane anymore yeah they're nuts
that's like hundreds of dollars for a
[__] tree yeah I like to get it up
early though I know did you do one this
year [__] yeah yeah we didn't do one had
to [__] move it back and forth when
they were digging that a hole in my wall
oh yeah that's
right I like it I like that it makes
watching TV nice and cozy I totally
agree I just uh between my tra between
our travel and my wife's travel we just
been [__] we so wait so you you don't
have one in the apartment either no no
tree I didn't I didn't there was a a
part this I didn't see my wife for three
weeks three and a half weeks I would
have Tak I would have got heat for that
I had the my wife was gone the bird was
home when we got back from somewhere and
then we got back from somewhere and then
left somewhere didn't we yeah I don't
remember uh yeah I had to get it that
night I think we got home and then I
started hearing oh I guess you're not
going to be
a let's go get in the car yeah let's go
just get it boom you decorated tomorrow
I think I was leaving again the next day
yeah there was no point for us cuz
neither one of us were home for most of
all of December we we've been gone up
until today up until 2 days ago I've
just been in my apartment with my cat
eating
beans like like a true
American gang we love you to death yeah
gang happy holidays Merry Christmas uh
this was fun that this fell on a on a
release day oh yeah F happy think this
is the first time Chris I think we had
like a Christmas Eve maybe once or twice
but a Christmas day is [__] awesome
uh you know we love you thank you so
much for all the support happy safe
healthy holidays you know we love you
and we'll see you next week peace peace